meanwhile cbs news has learned that
president biden could soon be heading to
europe to meet with nato allies
meanwhile ukraine's president zielinski
is expected to address congress tomorrow
as part of his effort to mobilize
international support against the
russian invasion nancy cordes is
following all of this from the white
house nancy good morning we understand
that the united states is talking to
china as well warning the country
against backing russia
good morning well russia doesn't have
many allies in this fight but a senior
administration official says the white
house is concerned about china's
alignment with russia and that concern
was conveyed directly to chinese
officials when they sat down in rome
with national security adviser jake
sullivan for what was described to us as
an intense seven-hour meeting yesterday
sullivan warned them there will be
consequences for china's relationships
around the world if it responds to
russia's requests for economic and
military aid now china and russia have
denied there's been any request for help
the kremlin saying quote russia
possesses its own independent potential
to continue the operation it's going
according to plan and will be completed
on time and in full
but financial analysts around the world
predict that russia could default on its
debts as soon as tomorrow as sanctions
drive down the value of the ruble now
sources tell us that plans are taking
shape for a trip by president biden to
meet with nato allies in europe as early
as next week and how's this for a show
of bravery and solidarity as the bombs
rained down the leaders of poland the
czech republic and slovenia are all
traveling by train to kiev this morning
to meet in person with ukrainian
president vladimir zelansky
what a picture that must be thank you
very much nancy